هل يحتاج الاطفال حقا الى ادويه السعال
والزكام عند الاصابه بنزلات البرد
مساله تثار فعليا داخل مرجعيات طبيه كبرى
من حول العالم وتوصيات صدرت قبل فتره من
قبل بعض هذه المرجعيات بتجنب اعطاء
الاطفال تحت سن معين ادويه لمكافحه الكحه
والسعال الموضوع يطرح مجددا اليوم مع ما
نقلته وكاله رويترز عن مصدر قريب من منظمه
الصحه العالميه من ان المنظمه الدوليه
تدرس فاذا كانت ستنصح العائلات على مستوى
العالم بمراجعه استخدام شراب السعال
للاطفال بشكل عام في حين ان الاسئله حول
سلامه بعض هذه المنتجات لم يتم محلها وقال
المصدر ان خبراء منظمه الصحه العالميه
يقيمون الادله لمعرفه ما اذا كان هذه
المنتجات ضروريه من الناحيه الطبيه
للاطفال ام لا يذكر ان الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه لا توصي بالادويه التي تصرف دون
وصفه طبيه لاعراض السعال والبرد لدى
الاطفال الذين اتقله اعمارهم عن عامين
لانها قد تسبب اثار جانبيه خطيره وقد تهدد
الحياه
معنا من باريس الدكتور انطوان اشقر
استشاري الامراض الصدريه والجهاز التنفسي
مرحبا دكتور يعني يبدو ال ااه يبدو الامر
اخطر مما كنا نتوقع على الصعيد المستهلكين
نحن كعائلات لدينا اطفال ولدينا امراض
شتاء بالاضافه لكونه همم يعني قد لا تغيب
همم ما مدى خطوره يعني هذا التسريب الاخير
مرحبا لك والمشاهدينك اولا اريد ان اذكر
ان للاهل خاصه اكان اطفال او كبار السن
عدم استعمال اي دواء دون وصفه طبيبيه عدم
شراء اي دواء عبر الانترنت لاننا لا نعرف
مصدره لن انسى ان هناك اطباء هناك صيادله
دورهم هو النصح وخاصه استعمال دواء ناجح
بالنسبه لادويه السعال ليس هناك
للسعال ناجح لا يستعمل اي دواء للسعال الا
في حالات معينه ممكن ان يكون السؤال يشكل
خطرا او يشكل ضيق تنفس ممكن استعمال بعد
الادويه
يعني انا احاول ان اكون مكان المشاهد
العادي ويا رب العائله الذي اذا ما
استثنينا الشراء المباشر من الصيدليات او
عبر الانترنت هذا موضوع مختلف ما الذي
يكتبه الاطباء
للمرضى وللاطفال تحديدا اا وقت السؤال اذا
اذا كان كما قلت لا يوجد دواء
السعال الذي تتكلم عنه وزاره منظمه الصحه
العالميه هو ده فقط
للسمتونس يعني ايه للسعال وليس علاج
دا المسبب للسعال هناك السعال حسب تصنيفه
اذا كان السعال ناتج عن مرض الربو هناك
ادويه مخصصه له مثل الكورتيزون الى اخره
اما الادويه التي حصلت منها منظمه الصحه
هي ادويه كانت ملوثه ولا تتوافق مع الشروط
العالميه مثلا وجد في هذه الادويه التي
سببت اكثر من 300 حاله وفاه عند الاطفال
دول الخمسه بالعمر قال هو ماده كيميائيه
تستعمل في الصناعه
وتستعمل للاغراض ضد الجليد هذا يسبب حالات
وفيات يسبب ضيق تنفس ويسبب اضطرابات في
القلب
وكوما اذا ما ما يوصف هو لتخفيف الاعراض
وليس لحل مشكله سبب هذا السعال
لكن هذا السبب في البلدان الغربيه لا يوجد
اي دواء مرخص من وزاره الصحه لشرائيه طيب
ما خطوره الاجتماعيه وان كان لتخفيف
الاعراض فقط ولا يحل المشكله لكن ما خطوره
الخطوره الفعليه لهذه الادويه
اذا كانت ملوثه وغير معروفه المصدر مثل
نقل كانت هناك مواد كيميائيه ممكن ان تؤدي
الى وفيات اما بعض الادويه التي تستعمل في
الصيدليات تخفف من هذا العارض بنوع من
مضادات الحساسيه لان نعتقد ان السعال انا
كطبيب امراض نفسيه التنفسيه انا احترم
السعال لانه رده فعل على مشكله ما ممكن ان
تؤديني او تؤدي الى تشخيص هذا المرض
السعال هو حال همم
رده فعل هذه من باريس الدكتور انطوان اشقر
استشاري الامراض الصدريه والجهاز التنفسي
شكرا لوجودك معنا